most mornings at 4:45 a.m. the alarm
goes off beside my bed the coffee goes
off about the same time on a timer I'll
need it about then Sharon and I get up
and spend a little time talking and
drinking coffee and praying and catching
up on our Bible and scanning through
what's happening in the news and I
always jump I jump on TweetDeck and just
see what's happening out there in the
world on Twitter and I always find some
interesting stuff about you know what
5:30 6:00 in the morning or something
like that
and this morning is no exception now
here's my rule about Twitter okay I will
not come after you personally on Twitter
unless you call me out and then I might
respond if you call me out and so I am I
do not feel like I am prohibited from
responding when you trash me I'm not
prohibited from responding now there are
people that say oh just ignore everybody
don't be thin-skinned well I'm not
thin-skinned but I just think it's
always interesting that you're allowed
to say whatever the flip you want to say
and I'm not allowed to say anything back
so I just always just let won't let you
know rules for Dave Ramsey Twitter is
this if you use my name anywhere in the
social media universe I might see it and
I might respond I might likely have fun
with you and make fun of you that's
possible or I could use use an object
lesson which is what I'm gonna do today
so apparently there's an article
floating around which I hadn't seen
until this morning and I did look it up
about jay-z the rapper jay-z he had one
expensive night out in Manhattan on
Sunday according to this article on Fox
News dropping more than 110 thousand
dollars
to celebrate the birthday of Juan Perez
his close friend and the president of
rock Nation sports Jay skipped the
all-star game and took one and a group
of rock nation execs to Zuma in Midtown
for dinner which is a nice place picking
up the tab there for 13 grand then the
group headed down to made in Mexico and
in would spending nine thousand dollars
on drinks including jay-z's cognac his
appealing
Brande followed by a stop at a nearby
nightclub playroom where even though
they were at by this point down to a
group of six they ordered and paid full
price for forty bottles of Ace of Spades
champagne which is really nice champagne
also owned by jay-z the stunt playroom
server posted J's check on snapchat
which came to a whopping ninety one
thousand one hundred thirty five dollars
that was his bar tab ninety one thousand
one hundred thirty five dollars and
included an epic eleven thousand dollar
tip well played jay-z and now I tell you
I'm a a child of the 70s and so I'm more
like Boston journey heart Eagles so rap
wasn't even invented back when I was
cool by the time rap came around I
wasn't cool and so I've never really
developed a taste for it but I have been
so intrigued by the rapper's even though
it's not my I don't listen to rap music
I'm not against it I'm not mad at it's
just not my style and yeah I've gotten
to meet several of them and hang out and
they they are an interesting crew we got
one that does some stuff on money that
comes on the air here with me it's a
great guy jay-z if by all accounts is
one of the world's best businessmen he
makes a lot of money he does a great job
managing his business and you know he's
got a line of his guys on line of
champagne he's got his own line of
cognac he's got his own line of this his
own line of that and so not only is he
made a bazillion dollars as a music
artist and is a world-class legitimate
music artist obviously buddies he's a
great business guy apparently I've never
met him I don't know him but I mean I've
just known this you know one degree two
degrees of separation for years about
jay-z and I don't know anything about
his character I don't know the guy at
all but he makes a lot of money he does
he manages his business affairs very
well by all appearances and so I just
looked it up I thought you drop you drop
a hundred grand
91 grand plus an 11 grand tip in a
nightclub you drop a hundred grand I
wonder what you make
because people always go WOW that I just
that's unbelievable well apparently he
made 42 million dollars in 2017 and he
dropped a hundred grand last night or
night before last or whatever it was
which I it's hard for I mean I grew up
in Antioch Tennessee to get my head
around dropping 100 grand on a bar tab I
can't get my brain wrapped around that
emotionally I but it always helps me and
there for you to do ratios on things and
so I just start taking zeros off so what
if you were a doctor and you made or
whatever an Indian chief I don't know
what you are and you make a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars a year I'm sorry
four hundred and twenty thousand dollars
here he makes forty-two million let's
say you made four hundred and twenty
thousand dollars a year him dropping a
hundred grand on a night on the town
would be at making forty-two million
would be like someone making four
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year spending a hundred dollars if you
make forty-two thousand dollars a year
it would be like you spending ten
dollars in other words he's okay it's
weird for you and me because our incomes
are not forty two million dollars a year
I've got a very nice income it's my
forty billion a year and so it's weird
to look at somebody spend 100 grand and
well you could feed starving children
well who says he doesn't say feed
starving children shut up we don't know
what he does or doesn't do but this kept
this idea that you have to hate on jay-z
for dropping 100 grand when the guy's a
world class business guy world class
artist at what he does again I'm not
defending him because he's a friend of
mine I don't even know him
but I'm just defending the concept a
he's earned the right B he didn't hurt
anybody
see he really didn't spend that much
because he bought his own stuff so by
the time he goes back through wholesale
and back into his account he's gonna
make money I mean he he paid full price
at the restaurant he didn't mess around
with him there
but I mean is his stuff that got sold to
the restaurant hello
the champagne and the cognac that is his
line so I'm sure I mean I don't know
whether there's licensing deal or
whether he actually owns those
businesses but you know there was it
wasn't a net of 100 but even if it
wasn't a net of a hundred Rand even if
he wasn't buying his own stuff if you
make 42 million dollars a year and you
spend a hundred thousand dollars on a
night on the town that's like someone
making four hundred and twenty thousand
dollars spending a hundred dollars or
someone's making forty two thousand
spending ten dollars now when we come
back from the break here's what we're
going to address in the next segment guy
tweets I'm up to my elbows in every day
making a third of this in a year or was
it makes thirty thousand dollars a year
and I'm the lazy self entitled
millennial for wanting to make more
money I clearly have a different
definition of lazy self entitled than
the sean hannity and dave ramsey crowd
and he prints out a picture of jay-z's
spending the picture of the ticket that
was out there for ninety one thousand
dollars plus eleven thousand dollar tip
not a bad tip not twenty percent but not
a bad tip so let's address this when we
come back it's something to talk about
because you called me out dude so we're
gonna talk about this because it's an
interesting lesson for you to learn this
is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
okay so I ended up getting in the middle
of this because some guy calls me out on
Twitter so JC has an adjacent and
businessman makes forty two million a
year and has a great night on the town
buying ace of spades champagne which is
his own champagne at a club runs up a
ninety one thousand dollar tab puts in
$11,000 tip on it drops one hundred
grand in one night he makes forty two
million a year last year awesome good
for him I'm proud for him
and by the way hands out he's seen
handing out bottles to other tables in
the club according to the article as
well and if you don't know Asus paid
champagnes about three hundred bucks a
bottle okay it's like Dom Perignon okay
I mean it's pretty serious I don't know
if it says good necessarily I'm not a
champagne connoisseur but it's about the
same price point in other words and so
that's like someone making four hundred
twenty thousand dollars a year spending
a hundred bucks in one night that's like
someone making forty two thousand
dollars a you're spending ten dollars in
one night well that's opulent that's
gaudy that is over the top that's
extravagant you shouldn't do that says
you see there's the problem we have an
America you get to figure out what jay-z
does with his money didn't do anything
wrong he was celebrating his friend
being generous to other tables promoting
his own brand of his product in do
anything wrong is it does it blow my
mind that you can drop a hundred grand
yeah I admit emotionally it blows my
mind
but then a guy comes on Twitter and says
I'm up to my elbows in every day making
a third of this in a year thirty
thousand I guess and I'm the lazy self
entitled millennial for wanting to make
more money I clearly have a very
different definition of lazy self
entitled than the Sean Hannity Dave
Ramsey crowd and I can't speak for the
Sean Hannity crowd I don't know except
for the extent they overlap with my
crowd but I will tell you two things
number one I take offense to the idea
that I somehow don't like Millennials
because I have defended Millennials many
times here on the air I have said I have
a ton of them working for me here and
the ones that work for me are awesome
now there are two types of millennial
sucks
and awesome there's no middle ground we
love Millennials that are missional and
driven
and man that there they'll fight their
fight to win I love them I got a bunch
of them on my team my children are
Millennials so I'm not anti millennial
millennial is an age group it's not a
mindset is there a percentage of them
that are participation trophy living in
their mother's basement of whiners yeah
yeah there is this guy is apparently one
of them and so I mean that's the deal
right so why are you griping if you make
thirty thousand dollars a year about
jay-z's success ha now that's what I
wanted to talk about right there because
see there's an in let me just tell you
there's a couple things in your
character that pre Dupree depose you to
being successful that's said that wrong
but anyway predispose you to being
successful that's the cracker work right
proper word okay one of one of the
things that predisposes you to being
successful is gratitude grateful people
are highly attractive whether you're a
millennial or your baby boomer or
whatever you are bitterness envy
jealousy predispose you to continue to
be a failure in life and so if you want
to throw stones through other people's
window because you don't have what they
have
I will tell you that predisposes you to
not win the chances of you winning go
down when you do that very few people
sit in whine and gripe about other
people's success and on their way to
becoming successful
it's very rare the people that become
successful almost always are people who
celebrate other people success and so
number one I'm not against Millennials
I'm for Millennials and I don't think
they're lazy self-entitled all of them
but I think some of them are and some
baby boomers are lazy and self-entitled
and some Xers and gin wires and
else are lazy and self-entitled lazy in
self-entitled is a thing it's not an age
and I'm wanting to make my make a third
of this and I'm wanting to make more
money no you're not wanting to make more
money what you're saying in your tweet
is you want somebody to give you more
money because you breathe air that's
lazy and self-entitled if you want to
make more than jay-z go do more than
jay-z if you want to make more than
$30,000 a year go do more than people
that make $30,000 a year I I've made
$30,000 a year I've made last one year I
made six thousand bucks god it's a long
year it's awful listen let me just tell
you if you won't make more money you can
make more money but griping about
jay-z's bar tab and indicating that you
don't make enough because he has a bar
tab that makes us three times what you
make in a year is not an indication of a
societal problem it's an indication that
you are jealous worse than that you're
envious jealousy is I want what you have
envious is I don't want you to have what
you have because I don't think I can get
it well I'll never have a car like that
so you shouldn't be allowed to I'm not
gonna get an inheritance so you
shouldn't be allowed to I'm not able to
blank blank blank so you shouldn't be
allowed to that's envious envy is an
evil spirit that is loose in the land of
America today envy and jealousy is an
evil spirit and it has invaded some of
you of all age groups well the one
percenters the evil one percenters the
evil the evil millionaires the evil fat
cats on Wall Street the evil this and
you assume automatically that someone
that has more than you has done
something wrong to get there and should
have it taken away from them that
be careful with envy because let me give
you a ratio if you make a household
income of $34,000 a year up to your
elbows in bleep every day you're in the
top 1% of income earners in the world so
someone in a different country could
look over here in a different setting
that makes a lot less than you and say
oh I don't you know I don't make that in
10 years and you make that because
you're in the United States and you make
$34,000 a year and you shouldn't have
that because I don't think I ever will
that is a dangerous thing if you catch
yourself being jealous or even worse
envious of someone else's success that
is setting you up to remain not only
bitter but in failure celebrate other
people's success celebrate other
people's success defend their right to
go and be successful there are people in
this world that are better looking than
Dave Ramsey as a matter fact there's a
lot of them there are people in this
world that are a lot more talented than
Dave Ramsey as a matter of fact there's
a lot of them there are people in this
world that are smarter than Dave Ramsey
as a matter of fact there's a lot of
them there's a few people not many of
them that work harder than Dave Ramsey
but and every one of those in every one
of those cases are doing if they're
doing something with their talents their
gifts their intellect their looks in the
marketplace they make more than I make
but I'm not bad I'm not mad at Beyonce
she's a much better dancer than I am and
I suspect most of y'all would rather
look at her on a screen than me and I
wouldn't blame you and she makes a lot
more than I make I'm not mad at Bill
Gates I'm not mad at Warren Buffett I'm
not mad at hopeful
they all got more and I got I'm kind of
I'm happy that they have succeeded and
every one of those by the way started
with nothing most of those I just
mentioned are billionaires if not multi
billionaires be careful of jealousy and
envy it says more about you than it does
the society it says more about you than
it does capitalism it says more about
you than it does a spiritual walk of
someone else be careful when you accuse
someone else of being extravagant
opulent or out of control with their
spending you take care of you that's a
full-time job